[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm pbhd here and
this is my tesla model s i named it
phantom this is not apollo which was the
car i had before this one and apollo was
great but the lease was up so i got into
a newer tesla model s after it and as
soon as i get into this car i
immediately notice
there's all these little things that are
different about it which got me thinking
about how teslas change over time
and how that's the best
and worst thing about them so if you
were to look at the the window sticker
or the registration on phantom it would
say that it's a 2020 tesla model s
performance but the thing is tesla
doesn't really do model year updates
like pretty much every other car
manufacturer instead what they do is a
steady series of slowly ongoing constant
minor changes that over time add up to a
bigger difference and when i say minor
changes i mean like really minor so the
first couple days in phantom i noticed a
couple little things all of which i
liked by the way first of all the trim
around the main screen is now matte dark
gray like space gray instead of the
previous chrome
and the trim in the air vents is also
now matte black instead of lighter and
then this whole front dashboard this
whole top here is now all leather
instead of before it was half leather
half alcantara
the cover of the storage between the
seats this used to be just black plastic
now it's a carbon fiber matching the
trim of the car and then there's the
seats of the car and they change the
seats all the time in teslas if you
follow this but the new ones here these
have this motorized telescoping memory
headrest that goes up or down for taller
or shorter passengers the list goes on
and on
and i notice all these and they're all
pretty small minor inconsequential who
would even notice or care
but there's also been a couple
medium-sized changes so at some point
between 2016 and 2019 they upgraded the
computers behind that touch screen
making the ui noticeably faster and
smoother and more responsive and
supporting more features like arcade
games and youtube and netflix that older
cars like apollo don't support they also
moved from a two camera setup to a six
camera setup for the autopilot system
that now supports more advanced navigate
on autopilot and a dash cam feature
built into the car that again older cars
just straight up don't have and then
there are the huge changes the major
ones these are the ones that get named
these are the ones that would probably
be worthy of an actual
model update like with other car
manufacturers so the newest one is the
latest air suspension and drivetrain
update called raven which literally
added miles to the range of the car and
changed the feel of the drive and
there's also the great front nose cone
refresh in 2016 where they went from the
black plastic nose cone to the new front
end here which to me looks a lot better
and also just a few weeks from that in
2016 there was the announcement of the
p100d the first time they offered a 100
kilowatt hour battery in their lineup
and it was at that point that i decided
okay that's a major update this is a
good time to buy you see these constant
rolling changes whether you're a
customer or the company itself are both
a good thing and a bad thing for tesla
it's a good strategic manufacturing
decision to simplify manufacturing as
much as possible to streamline it and
often that just means removing options
simplifying everything getting rid of
skus that you don't ship as much so all
you really can choose as options when
you custom build a tesla model s is
performance or long range
wheel type
paint color
and then just one of three interior
trims
then autopilot and actually the
performance versus long range by the way
are not even a different battery size
they're just a motor and inverter
difference so they've completely
eliminated all of the smaller battery
sizes from their lineup every tesla
model s that ships has the same battery
that is that is a really small number of
options for a premium luxury car but
that also means
the day you decide to get a tesla
that version of the car you're getting
will be the best version of the car
there's ever been probably even better
than if you had bought it a month or two
ago like a piece of tech it's the best
version ever usually but that also means
that the tesla you'd be considering
getting you're never really sure if it's
about to be updated by a new
sized or plaid sized update that's just
again the nature of buying tech but
easily the biggest most valuable thing
in all of this
is the software updates these cars get a
lot of software updates in fact since
i've gotten that car it's gotten more
software updates than my phone has and
in that time it's gotten faster it's got
new features new launch control the
autopilot now recognizes and reacts to
new things and shows animations
differently it's a lot so if rule number
one of tech is never buy a product for
the promise of future updates is tesla
breaking this rule well
they're trying to
because it helps them a lot for people
to trust that and and remember that
their cars get better with software
updates i think the best example of this
would be
the summon feature so in the tesla app
there's been a summon feature and it's
been there for years and way back at the
very beginning it was dead simple it was
just forward or backward so basically
you could just summon the car in a
straight line forward or backward out of
tight spaces
you know i guess kind of clutch if
someone parks really close to you and
you can't get in the door so you can
summon it out
neat but honestly it's it's not much
more than a party trick at the beginning
then they start adding features it can
kind of turn a little bit it does the
mirror folding it gets homelink support
so now it can sort of maneuver out of a
tight driveway space every day and open
and close the garage door if you wanted
to but now in 2020
many updates later there's a full-on
smart summon
which will just have the car find you
anywhere open up the app summon the car
to you
it'll find you
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay so technically speaking
that was a success but
in
every other way
that was kind of a nightmare i mean the
feature the idea the idea is there and
it makes perfect sense in an ideal world
you're at a mall it's raining you walk
outside with all your bags you don't
want to walk through the rain so you
summon the car it comes from the parking
lot right up to the door and finds you
you never get wet you get right into
your car
uh
but in reality it's still kind of a work
in progress first of all there's a limit
to how far away it can smart summon
feels like about 100 150 yards before
you're outside the circle and it won't
let you summon at all but once you press
summon the car wakes up and as long as
you hold that button down in the app the
car will continue along this path it's
drawn using gps and imagery that it
figures out that it can get to you and
it'll keep you updated on what's
happening as it's following that path in
the app now i'm doing this in an empty
parking lot to minimize risk but even
from all the times i've tried this in a
half full parking lot in a full parking
lot smart summon
just does not drive like a regular human
driver it drives maybe like a human but
like a five-year-old human that can
barely see above the steering wheel so
it does see signs and intersections
usually it slows down for them and it'll
say when it is but sometimes it doesn't
it does see pedestrians and moving
objects again sometimes it slows down
for them which you would hope every time
it would slow down for pedestrians but
sometimes it just didn't and that's a
really weird look when this car with no
driver almost runs someone over and then
proceeds to drive over to you while
you're standing there holding the button
on your phone like sorry i didn't mean
to i'm just summoning my car to me i
didn't know it wasn't going to stop i
could have let go of the button but and
it just completely completely ignores
all the lines on the road which i guess
isn't actually that much of a problem by
itself but it just it makes it hard for
other drivers to deal with it when it's
not behaving predictably like a normal
driver would again i've tried this in
other active parking lots and it has not
gone well so that all sounds pretty
rough but the upside the upside is
people are willing to test this for
tesla they have thousands millions of
drivers and and fans and enthusiastic
users all over the world who are willing
to test this over and over and over and
over again and just keep using it anyway
and tesla will use all of that data from
all the successful and all the failed
attempts to turn around and work on new
software to make it better it's an
underrated competitive advantage tesla
is a tech and software company really as
much as it is a car company and it's the
reason their cars feel more high-tech
than the rest and as you know it's very
very rare that a car
improves over time we know about car
collectors trying to find cars that will
appreciate in value but usually when you
get a car you know you drive it off a
lot and just over time it slowly gets
worse and worse until it's too old and
it's time to replace it when you get a
tesla the way they want you to think
about it is you get the car
and it does get older but it gets softer
update maybe you get the new cheetah
launch mode stance and then it's getting
older and older but then new autopilot
update and it's getting older and older
but then a new software update and it
gets faster and it just doesn't
it's supposed to feel like you end up
with a better car
later after you bought it no wonder elon
keeps tweeting about the price of
self-driving going up over time and how
much its value is to the actual car and
that it's underpriced it's one of the
most variable options in any car in the
world it's software tesla's stance i'm
sure if you ask them would be please buy
autopilot even if you don't think you
need it just buy it and eventually maybe
try it once or twice use it fall in love
with it and then start putting hundreds
and thousands of miles in so that the
entire fleet can be learned from and all
this data can go back to tesla and they
can learn from it and they can push a
software update and make it even better
and you know what maybe that's not such
a bad thing
for the car world maybe cars should be
like pieces of tech and attempt to get
better over time just a thought maybe in
the comments section let me know what
you think that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]